[SPEAKER_00]: After his brief discussion with Folsom, Owen Black decided to excuse himself from the company of his companions and retire to the cabin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen Black realized that he had been too loose-lipped with Folsom.
[SPEAKER_00]: The charm of the young man had taken him by surprise and his own need to brag about his legend allowed
[SPEAKER_00]: The rumor he had heard about Kane and Toli's control over the Turtle Dragons to slip.
[SPEAKER_00]: He began to realize that Folsom had been playing him all along, stroking his ego to pump him for information.
[SPEAKER_00]: He looked out of the darkness at the cabin on the deck and saw Merrick and Folsom talking to one another in whispers.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he realized the line of questioning Folsom had been giving him and the amount of information that Folsom had not been willing to give up showed that Folsom was an agent, most likely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of Lord Jameis and Prince Gian himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen had always known that Merrick had been favored by Lord Jameis and had some resentment towards that because Captain Nato, Merrick's father, had once been his idol too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Captain Nato had denied Owen Black a commission
[SPEAKER_00]: In the Monmurgian Navy, basically citing his recklessness, even though he had the ability to be a raw leader, a natural leader.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, he distrusted his judgment, even though, in truth, he was cleverer than Merrick by far.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe not as good a seaman.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe not as natural a fit to understanding the waves and the sea.
[SPEAKER_00]: But good enough with men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Smart enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: NATO had told him he tended more towards the attributes of Captain Cross than he liked.
[SPEAKER_00]: And told Owen Black that he would have his commission in time, but should just be patient.
[SPEAKER_00]: He needed to learn humility and the new ways and work better with others to be able to be a true leader himself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen saw it all now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick was here on a mission.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he was alone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus
[SPEAKER_00]: Folsom, maybe unwitting, compatriots to Merrick, because that is how Jameis worked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Matching unwitting with witting and using them as he would.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, however, he was very concerned with.
[SPEAKER_00]: He knew Goug was not a man he could take, even though he could probably stand his own against the others.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tyrus would be a challenge, but Merrick he knew he would pummel into bloody pulp.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Goug was the linchpin.
[SPEAKER_00]: And whose side Goug landed on, that would determine the outcome.
[SPEAKER_00]: Suddenly he felt very alone and understood the truth of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were all against him.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were all trying to use him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And not in a good way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not in a useful way where you see a compatriot, an ally who can do good by you and you can do good by them, making money together in some common venture.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was the product.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was the one that was going to be bought and sold.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen sat back in his cabin and pulled out a bottle of the black rum, pouring himself a dream of it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He knew there would be no turtle dragons attacking tonight, and he let too much information slip.
[SPEAKER_00]: He would see in the days to come whether Folsom gave his secret up or not, and if he did, he would know the truth of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick was sent to spy on him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Folsom, that charming young lad who had flattered him the entire sail out of Monmurg up the coast, a person he had come to see as a friend and whose company he had enjoyed, that was Merrick's whore, and he had been taken by it.
[SPEAKER_00]: He downed a shot of the Black Realm, eased back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, they'd be in Red Shore soon.
[SPEAKER_00]: And once there, he would have resources that none of them would have.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'd make sure that his business was unaffected.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'd also make sure that Lord Jameis never knew the secrets of Kane Tolley.
[SPEAKER_00]: Someone, a benefactor, who had given him much, and he expected more from.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not go well with him, going against the men of Monmurg, one of them his cousins per se, two of which he felt good of.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, well, Gouge had beaten him silly one night after all, so that could be thought of as revenge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe death, he didn't know quite yet.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was too bad Kane Tolley had passed on out of the area because he would have felt better if he could have just imprisoned his compatriots, putting them out on Kane's fortress island, guarded by the hundreds of hobgoblins that went there.